monsieur chirac on se retrouve ce soir
il vous reste en quelque sorte case où
il peut convaincre maintenant tout de
suite ma première question je voudrais
revenir sur le débat notre soir avec
françois mitterrand et j'ai eu un peu
l'impression qu'ils vous avez fait le
coup du mépris du dédain et j'ai pas
compris pourquoi voulait pas relevé plus
brutalement d'avoir c'est dans sa nature
de faire le coup du mépris ensuite
venant de lui
cela ne me perturbe pas enfin je préféré
laisser naturellement aux
téléspectateurs le soin de juger ce
n'est pas un argument de campagne que
d'afficher son mépris et vous croyez
qu'ils ont senti ainsi l'été sécateur je
n'en sais rien nous le verrons
probablement dommage rocha nantes et
vous appelez ostensiblement monsieur
promu nice pour margaux en serrant bien
entendu bien entendu mais la vérité
c'est que ce qui m'a paru très claire
dans ce débat et j'espère que cela a été
compris ainsi ces deux choses la
première c'est qu'il n'a vous l'aurez
observé rien proposé il s'est uniquement
référer au passé jusqu'à y compris la
loi falloux et la deuxième et qui m'a
beaucoup choqué et je veux dire qu'il
m'a vraiment confirmé dans mon jugement
sur ses capacités à assumer le destin de
notre pays dans une réflexion qui la
pète sur des échanges de vue que nous
avions eu en tête à tête il a travesti
la sphère gordji nageurs ont déjà dit
revenant il a travesti la vérité et ceci
n'est absolument pas acceptable
ça m'a donné à réfléchir sur beaucoup de
choses du passé de son passé il on n'a
pas le droit de dire là de dire une
contre vérité aux français sur tout
enfin je veux dire avec un apport
extraordinaire devant quelqu'un qui sait
parfaitement qu'elle reviendrait en nous
regardant dans les yeux non en évitant
awidan on ne voyait pas oui il n'avait
pas voulu qu'il y ait de plan-de-cuques
mais en évitant de me regarder dans les
yeux et ça vous savez ça m'a vraiment de
dire choqué au plus profond de modèle
alors après le coup du mépris il semble
actuellement il vous fasse le coup de la
honte c'est à dire que quand vous
assimilant avec les racistes etc
l'app l'impression que sur ce terrain
vous l'avez laissé la voie libre et qu
une sorte de complexe côté jamais aucun
complexe
d'abord parce que le président léopold
sédar senghor le rappelait récemment je
n'ai pas de preuve à donner dans ce
domaine en revanche que je voudrais dire
c'est que le courant protestataires
d'extrême droite auquel il se réfère
aujourd'hui mais c'est lui qui l'a créé
il n'existait pas en 80 lits lavera
danser dans sa représentation
parlementaire il juste pas une
représenté 1 2 % des voix aujourd'hui 15
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
laxisme de la politique de monsieur
mitterrand pendant cinq ans à créer les
conditions objectives de ce
développement je crois d'ailleurs qu'il
y était favorable
alors la tension ou des pneus il a fait
la créer les conditions du développement
de d'un extrémisme nommé à créer de bout
en bout et il ne les agréent
probablement un consomme inconsciemment
ou par incompétence mais aussi
volontairement pour créer une
perturbation c'est bien dans dans sa
manière de faire perturbations dans la
majorité
il a d'ailleurs parfaitement réussi
ensuite il a officialisé en quelque
sorte ce courant par la réforme de la
loi électorale et la proportionnelle
après il lui a donné
je dirais un coup de pouce en parlant du
vote des étrangers dont il ne parle plus
aujourd'hui mais qui permettait là
encore d'amplifier le courant empirique
il ne l'a jamais proposé
oui j'ai un poliquement hypocrite et
aujourd'hui il dit mais c'est moi le
pompier mais le pompier pour éteindre et
quel feu à feu que lui même a allumé
alors est il le mieux à même de
maîtriser ces phénomènes non est-ce que
vous avez des complexes à parler des
valeurs là lens l2 ce pays d'abord je
n'ai aucun complexe
mais je voudrais dire deux choses la
première c'est que je ne me laisserai
pas englué dans un débat théorique sur
des valeurs alors que
vrai problème que le candidat socialiste
veut éviter d'évoquer c'est le chômage
c'est l'identité nationale c'est
l'immigration c'est la pauvreté et le
moyen de lutter contre celle-ci c'est la
solidarité nationale c'est la protection
sociale c'est à dire la sécurité sociale
et le rétablissement de ses comptes
c'est les investissements de nos
entreprises pour qu'elles créent des
emplois et qu'elles soient compétitifs
demain en 1992 dans l'europe c'est la
préparation des grands équipements
français qui nous permettront de bien
être articulé sur les grands courants
d'échangés européens et de créer chez
nous la richesse c'est des moyens de
sauvegarder les intérêts des artisans
des commerçants des paysans des
industriels des professions libérales
dans les grands débats qui auront lieu
pour achever cette europe de 92 avec nos
partenaires
c'est ça les problèmes alors les débats
sur les valeurs monsieur mitterrand il
consacre l'essentiel de son propos
parce qu'il a peur de vrai débat sur les
problèmes les prêts will reiser monsieur
chirac en clair que les socialistes
monsieur mitterrand cherche à escamoter
les vrais débats en utilisant ce faux
débat sur les sur les vraies valeurs
pour une raison simple c'est qu'ils ont
toujours été incapable et leurs bilans
l'a bien montré de d'apporter des
réponses aux vrais problèmes
alors il s'évade dans les valeurs mais
sur les valeurs je dirais une deuxième
chose c'est que moi j'appartiens à une
famille la famille gaulliste je suis
étroitement et fraternellement associé
avec une autre famille la famille
centriste libéral radical indépendante
et nous sommes ensemble porter depuis
toujours d'un certain nombre de
convictions relatifs à la sécurité qui
conditionne la liberté des hommes
relatifs à la famille qui conditionne la
vie même de notre société relatifs à la
patrie et à l'engagement qu'on doit
avoir pour la défendre quoi qu'il arrive
dans toutes les circonstances et que ce
n'est certainement pas le candidat
socialiste ou les socialistes qui me
donneront à cet égard des leçons ou des
leçons de morale
sur des valeurs qui ont toujours été les
miennes et je ne ne lui donnerait pas le
débat mais ce n'est pas ce débat qui est
en cause aujourd'hui entre nous le vrai
débat c'est comment répondre aux
problèmes des français et de la france
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et se
débat le candidat socialiste le fuit et
c'est ce que je lui reproche alors
changeons de sujet mais abordons aussi
dramatique aussi présents la pensée les
français c'est la nouvelle calédonie
d'abord une interrogation pourquoi
est-ce que vous n'agissez pas plus
nettement pour libérer ces malheureux
gendarmes qui sont actuellement
emprisonnés dans des conditions
désastreuses
tout simplement parce qu'il s'agit d'une
prise d'otage un peu de la même nature
que celles auxquelles elle a été
confrontée dans le boeing récemment et
que nous devons faire en sorte
naturellement de ne pas mettre en danger
la vie de nos otages mais ce que je peux
vous dire je ne développerai pas plus ce
thème ce soir c'est que tout sera mis en
oeuvre
bien sûr pour libérer nos otages mais
surtout pour libérer notre honneur c'est
à dire pour faire en sorte que les
terroristes soit déféré à la justice et
répondent de leurs actes
alors je vais aller plus loin si vous me
permettez est ce que vous pourriez dire
ce soir que le fait que cette affaire
soit déclenchée quelques jours ou
quelques temps avant l'élection
présidentielle était un fait fortuit
c'est à dire c'est perçoit le fait du
hasard
naturellement pas les dirigeants
officiels du fln qu'est ce qui réduit à
sa plus stricte expression même dans le
milieu mélanésiens comme on l'a vu lors
des dernières élections présidentielle
régionales que monsieur mitterrand
essayer de faire annuler et que le
conseil constitutionnel a maintenu parce
qu'elle s'était déroulée parfaitement
normalement même le fln caisse l'a
reconnu c'est d'une affaire préparée de
longue date depuis plusieurs mois pour
équiper cette grotte pour monter cette
opération pour bénéficier des
complicités extérieures et des aides
étrangères nécessaires auraient revenir
un peu sur monsieur mitterrand lui même
elle vole critiqué sévèrement vous ne
pensez pas qu'il peut avoir changé et
que les hommes qui l'entourent peuvent
également d'avoir changé
si j'écoute que le propos des hommes qui
l'entourent indépendamment des appels
je dois dire sans complexe qu'ils font
actuellement à l'égard des électeurs du
front national
et ce qui d'ailleurs les discrédite pour
me donner quelques leçons que ce soit
dans ce domaine car moi je me comporte
avec dignité ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'un certain nombre des collaborateurs
du candidat socialiste s'il a changé ou
si l'on changé qu'il le dise
mais si nous on change et en intégrant
les préoccupations des français en
essayant d'y répondre par les seuls
moyens qui ont fait leurs preuves à
l'étranger en europe ou en france
pendant deux ans alors je leur dis dans
ce cas là vous avez probablement intérêt
à faire en sorte que je puisse continuer
à apporter ses solutions
vous n'êtes probablement pas les mieux à
même de le faire mais nous ne savons pas
rien dans le propos de monsieur mi
terrain ne permet de dire si la changer
ou non à la mairie c'est un chèque en
blanc qu'ils nous donneront sur comment
ça c'est de l'escroquerie
c'est de l'escroquerie mais comment
expliquez-vous que tu veux après des
sandales bien entendu tant de français
s'apprêtent à voter pour lui dimanche
sauf au dehors de même des sionistes
il faudrait d'abord être sûr que les
sondages sont justes ce n'est pas c'est
sûr et il n'y en a pas eu depuis une
dizaine de jours ce n'est pas ce que je
ressent personnellement et moi j'ai
toujours fait confiance au bon sens des
français
je suis sûr que les français lorsqu'ils
nous aurons à choisir c'est à dire a
décidé d'avoir se souviendront de leur
jugement en mars 86 à l'égard de ce
qu'avait été monsieur mitterrand
triomphant est investi des pleins
pouvoirs
qu'ils examineront d'un peu plus près ce
que avec bien les difficultés j'ai fait
avec ma majorité et qu'ils réfléchiront
à deux fois et par conséquent je pense
que l'espoir est encore permis pour une
france rassemblant tous les hommes
toutes les femmes qui se reconnaissent
dans les vertus du dynamisme de la
volonté de la ténacité à développer
notre pays envers une terre où la
justice sociale et mieux affirmée et qui
donc est capable de créer les moyens
pour cela elle les français ont envie de
tout ça je crois que les français sont
un peuple henry et lorenzo dont jour
monsieur mitterrand c'est à dire je suis
l'homme qui calme qui effectue tout va
bien ça c'est l'ambition de la
médiocrité
c'est en quelque sorte le flou
l'immobilisme qui cache tout le reste y
compris l' aventure moi je suis sûr que
les français sont dans leur grande
majorité c'est cela que je veux
rassembler qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche les hommes et des femmes
dynamiques qui se rendent parfaitement
compte que nous sommes confrontés à les
vrais problèmes qu'il faut lutter contre
le chômage contre la pauvreté qu'il faut
développer notre icône notre économie
créer les richesses qui nous permettra
d'être dynamique et compétitif demain
dans l'europe et que pour cela il faut
te une direction qui rassemble c'est
différentes valeurs sûres que arrivant à
la fin de la mission devrait poser une
dernière question qui va tout à fait
dans le sens de ce que vous vous êtes
dit de quoi parlera actant le 9 mai au
matin
je pense que si je suis élu ou parlera
immédiatement de l'action qui doit être
engagée pour répondre à ces
préoccupations qu'on ait évoqué tout à
l'heure et qui sont celles des français
si le candidat socialiste était là on
parlera naturellement d'abord des
combines politiques
et puis on s'apercevra qu'elle ne marche
pas parce que nous ne sommes plus sous
la quatrième république
et alors on parlera de l'élection
législative
mais ceci me conduite à une dernière
appréciation que j'ai évoquées hier soir
et que j'évoque les encore ce soir
si vous vous reconnaissez dans ce café
le candidat socialiste pendant cinq ans
et dans ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui alors
il faut voter pour lui si vous
considérez que les ports engagée pour le
redressement de notre pays par mon
gouvernement c'est-à-dire par moi même
soutenu par ma majorité qui me permet
immédiatement d'engager à nouveau
l'action gouvernementale alors il faut
voter pour moi mais si vous êtes des
hommes et des femmes responsables
rappelez vous qu'il faut voter qu'on ne
peut pas s'abstenir et que de toute
façon
s'abstenir c'est en réalité
mathématiquement voter pour monsieur
mitterrand alors je vous fais confiance